a historic decision that campaigners say
is a major step forward for climate
Justice it is so decided
no vote was needed the general assembly
deciding by consensus to ask the world's
highest court the international court of
justice to determine what obligations
countries have for the climate damage
they've caused festering climate
Injustice fits divisions and threatens
to paralyze Global Climate action
so excellencies for those on the front
lines already paying the price for
Global heating they did nothing to cause
climate Justice is also vital
recognition and a tool
recognition that all people on our
planet are of equal worth and the tool
to build resilience against spiraling
climate impacts the efforts to negotiate
this treaty were led by the Pacific
island of Vanuatu this was a end of a
very long campaign how did you feel in
that moment of a very very happy person
because uh
uh uh I can assure my kids and the kids
around the world
that the leaders of the countries of
This Global community
uh actually listening to
the plight of the future of this of
future of mankind
small island of Vanuatu suffered a
devastating Cyclone earlier this year
highlighting the fact it's a country
that's whole existence is threatened by
climate change
the original idea for the UN resolution
actually came from law students studying
here at the University of the South
Pacific one of them was Cynthia
it's it's real I I still can't believe
that we've gotten this far and it's it's
it's testamental a lot of um you know
the determination that you'd have it's a
testament to
you know when you'd uh moved by genuine
concern not only for their future but
the future of our generation is yet to
come at the end of the meeting the U.N
Secretary General told me it was a big
victory but un insiders say even though
this resolution passed by consensus
there are some major countries which
have a problem with it and they expect
some national submissions to the
international court of justice in an
effort to narrow the eventual ruling of
the judges James Bay's Al Jazeera of the
United Nations